now to present the Award for Best
Actress the winner of last year's Best
Actor Award unfilmed from Manila mr.
Marlon Brando writing it
hi hey we gone well here we are Manila
and the Pantages seat is just over there
you go out here and take this street
down about two blocks to the left then
you go straight 'yes four oh six seven
thousand miles short leg and of course
you get on the Hollywood Freeway and get
right off at vine in their yard -
Pantages Theatre that's what the award
for the best actress of the year is
about to be announced I'll give you the
nomination nominees are as follows Susan
Hayward for all cry tomorrow
Katy have fun for summertime Jennifer
Jones for love is a many-splendored
thing
Hahnemann yani for the Rose Tattoo and
Eleanor Parker for interrupted melody
and winner is the winner is an Aman
Yanni in the road
reward on this
Maurice Ichabod this of course is
missing Marisa Pavan and I know Oh heavy
you know you are I know you are
oh I know we should could be here she
would be so happy
yes what some move I prepare a speech I
don't know I I can't remember where Dean
had the same trouble I just want to
thank you all and I want to give you a
kiss for mommy thank you everyone
you got it we are very very sorry that
miss mañana couldn't be here tonight but
she's in Rome and I'm sure that you will
know of your excitement for her